[Applause]
well you're probably wondering why I
called you out here tonight I well the
truth is I I always wanted my name in
lights
so I changed my name to exit no rimshot
on that one [ __ ] guys but I I honestly I
I can't thank you enough all of you for
coming tonight and for the opportunity
to share with you a very personal
30-year journey for me performing
researching documenting which is now
over 60 interviews spanning seven
countries and when the project is
completed it will have a home here at
the Academy Film Archive
but what is an eccentric dancer you say
what is an eccentric well it's not
exotic dancing I gave that up a long
time ago I kept cold but the eccentric
dancer is really its own unique genre
it's usually a very highly skilled
dancer with extreme flexibility it
implements a very specific repertoire of
steps in pantomime and it's wrapped
around character in a visual narrative
and for me it all began in a ballet
class by taught by a vaudevillian named
John Zerby who had with very some very
lethal ground bomb on a dwindling career
as a ballet dancer and I learned my
first silly walk and I was hooked I was
18 and I was working as a Disney
animator when I immediately saw a
distinct parallel between character
animation and eccentric dance and I knew
this was bigger than just stick but this
was the essence of pantomime so I
tracked down every eccentric dancer of
odd villian I could find making them
cold calls and I'm dragging him out of
card games I'm dragging him into a dance
studio and I saw a living history that
was pure gold I then began creating any
possible venue to perform it
whether choreographing animation or
dancing in vaudeville programs or as the
Betsy Bird on the Muppet Show in London
and every encounter with every master
was an epiphany and still is but when I
saw the word eccentric dance on a saloon
poster in a pub from 1845 it really
sparked a mission for me to trace it
even further and discover where it came
from and when people began moving like
this and why
so I began reaching out last year to
scholars across the globe and there was
a universal language within every
culture communicating
and character and through a similar type
of exaggerated movement and it's really
ancient it's a big big story to tell and
I'm thrilled to be able to share a slice
of it with you tonight